So Matt, I'd like to take a look at another
category of reports that come out of your genome. And
I, those are called inherited gate conditions. And those include
things like cystic fibrosis and bloom syndrome, and sick cell anemia.
>> Oh, well, I, I know I'm not a carrier for
sickle cell anemia. But that makes sense, because I have a mainly
European background. And sickle cell anemia isn't prevalent of those with
European descent. However, in sub Saharan Africa, it is is more prevalent.
And you guys may remember
[FOREIGN],
who's from Kenya.
Has anyone in your family ever been affected by sickle cell anemia?
>> No. No one in my family has been affected by
sickle cell anemia. But I am aware of people around me who've
had it. Okay. Well, why don't we go take a look
at your results to see if, by any change, you're a carrier.
>> Sounds good.
>> Okay, great. Alright. So, now that we've logged into your profile
[INAUDIBLE].
we need to go up to my results, and look for the inherited conditions section.
>> And what does it say for you,
[INAUDIBLE]?
Let's find it.
>> We'll scroll down until you find the
sickle cell anemia report. There. Is that it?
>> This is it here. What does it say?
It says variant absent.
>> Variant absent. What does that mean, Joanna?
>> So, that means that you do not
carry a, one of the variants that's linked to
sickle cell anemia. So now we're looking at
the report itself, and there's some background information. Let's
scroll down to find your actual results and then we see, that is. It says you do
not have the s version of the HBB gene,
which is linked to Sickle Cell Anemia. Okay so,
it says here that a person with one copy
of the S version, typically does not have sickle cell
anemia, but can pass mutation to offspring. So does
that mean that the S allele is dominant or recessive?